Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to the Brookhaven Experiment demo.
One of the things that you guys said the last time I recorded a...
virtual reality game was that I needed to be a little bit smooooother in my motion.
So that you guys didn't get so sick but the only problem is that when I'm talking it's a little bit hard...
to do everything.
Also, you'll notice, I don't have headphones anymore because
if you were wondering yourself, "Why is Uncle Markimoo screaming at the top of his lungs like a freakin' idiot?"
well
It's 'cause I couldn't hear myself. And it's important to hear yourself because
you have no idea how loud you are. So I just ended up screaming very a lot.
That is so co - Look at this!
Just look at this! Are you seeing this?!
I mean, what else would you be looking at,
but that's so cool!
It's a backpack!!!!! :D
Why is that cool?!
*Gunshot* Hmm..
*Gunshot* Ka-bam!
*Gunshot* Boom! I blew them away
My bullets are disintegration bullets!
Bang!   (realises what he's done) Oh shit.....AHH fuck..
Okay
alright then
Wave one, huh?
They're coming from all the---Ah! I see you over there
Bam!
Did that work?
WHOA
*MarkiMoo wasting bullets*
YEAH!
*MarkiMoo wasting more bullets*
Oh that's so cool but he's not dead
that seems to be a problem and I'm a little tangled here
AH
Show yourself!
Show yourself, monsters of the darkNESS!
AHH!
He's not dead!
This seems to be a problem!
Ooh
You're too close
Okay, that guy's going down
Okay. So I was just missing
What're you doing over there?
Huh?!  Being a sassy?
You want it execution style?
Nope, I'm gonna miss--UAAH
I heard
Okay. You
No
Okay!
So my main problem is that I'm a terrible shot
and I'm going to get devoured to death
(nervously) OH Boy
They're coming from all sides---this is so weird!
I mean, considering it's virtual reality and this is the whole idea
but
It's just so disconcerting that these things are coming
towards me like this
Don't even think
that I can't move around
and dance and get tangled up
As such!
but it don't matter
'Cause my skills..
are unbeatable!
Just like-
(Nervously) Oooh gawd
This is slightly scary
Now this is just the demo---whoa
You were way too close there buddy
WAAY too close
Alright, who else is comin'?
From where and how?
Oh you!?
*gun clicks*
Don't you---uhuhhh
(Nervously) UHH
OOH THAT AIN'T GOOD
HOW DO I FIX THAT?
OH GAWD
TAKE MY FLASHLIGHT
OH DON'T COME NEAR ME
OH YOU SON OVABITCH
aH BEH BEH BEH BEH
OW-Did that work?
EUH
AHHHHAHA
YOU'RE SO SCARY!
AHHAAAH
What if I throw my gun at you? OW
He blooded my eyes up!
Well how was I supposed to do that?
Okay, so i'm gonna do that again but this time
imma let them get closer to me
before.. I waste all of my bullets.
(reading) 'You ran out of ammo. Try again?'
Well... yeah.
Alright. Let's do this.
I didn't even get past wave one
So I don't need this
Until they get nice and close [Kung Fu Mark activate]
and so once again
HI
(creepily) How are you doing?
(still creepy) My name is Markilplier
(creepily) You killed my father
(creepily) I'm going to kill YOU now
(still creepy voice, sarcastically) Don't even think about comin' any closer
IMM GONNA GET'CHA
(normally) I should have put the wrist straps on shouldn't I have?
Ok, rear
That---Yeah!
That's how we do!
Not until I see the blood in their pupils
AHHHH-Boink!
AHHH-Boink!
uh-oh
I didn't know---Ah-ha!
(creepy voice) Now I got 'cha!
(creepy voice) Now I am on the top of the food chain!
(creepy voice) Now i am the one with the knocks!!(▀̿Ĺ̯▀̿ ̿)
AAAHH-Boink!
Okay, this is much easier
I wonder also if when I reload I lose the rest of
the bullets in the clip because
That is something that happens in
HYPER REALISM [Nice bootah]
Okay. Goodbye!
Goodbye!
Goodbye! ...Uh-oh
AH shit!
Oh! sth-stay there!
Boink!
Boink! Got you!
Ah ha ha ha I am winner
Ew look at your grundle!
Actually, no one look at your grundle
No one wants to see that
Okay...Yooou!
You!
okay, so far so GOO
So far so goo, okay
Imma see this
Okay, so it does keep the bullets
You don't lose anything from just reloading
And I just have to be very
very stealthy
(creepy voice) WHO'S OVER THERE?!
(creepy voice) IS SOMEBODY OVER THERE?!
(creepy voice) How about over there?!
(creepy voice) WHOEY I THOUGHT I HEARD SOMETHING
(creepy voice, thoughtful) Huh.
UH-OH!
eh
(Normally) There we go.
So long as I aim correctly down the sights
How did-
How do.. like cops
hold it like this? Don't they?
Or something like that?
OH
Was that the sound of suc--YAAS
I survive-ved!
Whoa
(reading) 'Scavenging'?
AHH
YEAH!
I mean it seems like I did a lot better that that.
okay.
Yay!
What does mutilation mean?
I don't--
I don't want that.
I'm a nice guy.
OHkay
Grea--AHH
Why'd you throw numbers into my chest?
An upgrade?
Glow sights?
I'll that that
Yes! Let's go!
Let's do dis!
WHO WANTS SOME?
COME GET SOME
MARKIMOO IS READEH
MARKIMOO IS FEELIN' GOOD
I SEE YOU OVER THERE
You think you can hide from meee?
I'm gonna turn this off cause I don't need it
How do I-
There we go
Alright, so you, you
anybody else want to party?
Anybody else want a PIECE OF ME?
A delicious slice of Markimoo cake?
Well that's-
That is actually a little bit easier
Whoa you're big!*Mark freaking out*
WHOA you're big!*still freaking out*
WHOA YOU'RE BIG*MORE FREAKING OUT*
WHOA
THAT GUY WAS BIG
I DIDN'T KNOW THERE WERE GOING TO BE BIGGER ONES
[insert dick joke here]
OH okay
WHOA hey
Where'd you come from?
Okay
I did NOT know
there were going to--whoa
ah- heh
I- okay
nevermind then I thought I saw something
Whoa---hello
It's a big man
so they come charging at me when I shoot--
SO I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT
I'm gonna wait PATIENTLY
for everybody to get over here
* markimoo mating call*
Deedle deedle deel
Deedle deedle deel deel
Ah shit
Why'd I reload then?
okay
You--WHOA YOU'RE BI---AHHAH
OOH THAT'S SO SCARY!
AAH-what is wro--O-HO-KAY
OHAI
Sorry I was busy lookin--ohh he's gone now
*totally brave markimoo noises*
Oh hey buddy
How're you doing, friend?
Oh welcome to the party
AHHH
So scary! <:(
This is-
No one told me this was gonna be so--
Ohh, wha-
Whoaaah
What is that?
OH WHAT IS THAT?!
(nervously) OHH WHAT IS THAT?
AHH WHAT IS THAT
DO I NEED TO AIM?
I'M READY
YOU WANT SOME OF ME?
EHYEAH I'M RIGHT HERE
Ready and waiting
(nervously) whoa boy
whoa gwash
ah!
Did I do it?
Did I dones it?
OH okay thank you
Flashlight batteries?
Well that's not really glow sight batteries.
Wait glow sight-
How'd I turn on the glow sight?(Even though that's not how glow sights work.)
Laser sight?
That sounds better!
(reading) Uses custom batteries?
But wait-- (there's more)
I'm just-
Hang on a second!
this is-
but I thought-
Oh so was glow sight-
Well damn it!
Laser sight though, that sounds good
Wha--OOOOH
Look at dat!
Oooh-ho ho hoo
Well that's much better
I don't know how to turn that on and off though
Let's do it!
ALRIGHT
Now I got a laser sight
Hot tits!
That's awesome!
That's so cool!
Look at thaat!
I mean look at that!
I SAID LOOK AT THIS(OK O_O)
LOOK AT THIS AND MY SMOOTHNESS
I AM SO SMOOTH
I'm so swood and smooth
HAA!
Okay
So far so good
This is really worth it
but it does seem to be taking battery
I don't know how to turn it off
to conserve
because I don't want it on all the time
but at the same time
eh
ooh
Don't knock that around!
I placed that just specifically
Whatever
whatever
Okay
OOh that was close
If I'd been reloading when he was coming charging
that would have ended very poorly for me
See I'm still kinda worried about
the giant monster that was
stampeding through the city over there
I mean this game is called the Brookhaven Experiment?
I don't know if the experiment is that
I'm supposed to be in the middle of this
I don't know why I'm still standing
in the middle of my campground
in the middle of this abandoned area
where obviously things are going badly
(cheerfully) BUT WHATEVER
Sometimes I just wanna take in the sights
I mean that do lose a sense of self
when I'm doing this
Like, I lose an idea that I'm in my room
If- If like
If everything wasn't coiling up around my feet
in terms of the wires and everything
I would be doing
just
fine
with myself
TA-DAAH
any more?
Does anybody wanna come after me?
Does anybody
want something
to do with the
Markimoo?
What's that I hear?
The sound of death?
I meant to get that on the first try
but it doesn't matter
Hello!
Where are you now?
OH Gawd dammit
I meant to be over there again--
Now I gotta--ff- alright.
Laser batteries
but
but it's running out right now!
Right now it's running out!
But--da
But that's stupid!
That's stupid!
How do I turn it OFF?!
okay
WELL
FIDDLEY DIDDLEY ME
I'm just gonna sit here an--
in a puddle of pee
because I'm so scared that
I'm gonna die
Alright, come at me bro
What?
ho-HOLY CRAP!*Markimoo freakout time*
WHOA
WHOA there buddy
WHOA WHOA WHOA
HOO-- YOU GOT A VAGINA FACE
*totally manly scream*
*even manlier scream*
AAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
okay
well then
Okay
Alright
That was terrifying
My god
When was that supposed to be a thing?
That was horrifying!
okay
So long as another
giant guy doesn't come around
I think I'll be okay
whoa
taken care of him
Alright Imma let them get real close
cause I wanna see 'em
I want them to seeee me!
I want them to
see me!
(Singing) Bang bang bang
it's a dead zombie town
BABABABABABABA!
I don't even know if
he was dead by the end of that last shot
but he's dead now
And I should'a
I should've
worked this out better
so it wouldn't be so stupid on me
wait
Oh, that has a flashlight-
(delighted) oh!
Oh that's handy! :D
So when they get real close,
and I put my gun literally up underneath them,
[Gunshot] BANG!
They're DEAD!
Just like that, you zombie bastards!
By the way, this game...
I love this.
This is so cool. This is exactly what I wanted
out of like, a zombie shooter?
It's just *gunshot*
Aw, it's so satisfying! They're like right there!
They're RIGHT THERE!
And it's so scary! They're-
Whoah.
It's so scary! He was looming!
He was like RIGHT THERE!
I mean, MY GOD!
Alright, so bigger clips seems to be the only thing that I really want here
'cause everything else is temporary!
I don't need lasers, I have glow sights
or it has sights,
And I really only need them
to be close!
And then I can kill them right away
'cause I'm a freakin' badass!
Hello!~
*Multiple gunshots*
Alright...
Big Guy...
I'm looking for the big, big guys
Big guy? Anybody wanna tussle?
With the muscle??
HUHHH?
ANYBODY?
Aw, it's so weird. I hear 'em all around me.
That's another good thing about the 3D sound.
But DAMN.
I'm just looking for Big Guy!
So long as Big Guy's not coming, I'm gonna be perfectly okay.
No? No Big Guy? Anybody?
Anybody here?
No? Okay. Alright!
I guess I'm all alone! I guess he's SCARED.
Too scared of the Markimoo!
Hah?
Don't like dancing h-OHHH.
*bangbangbang*
Okay, you weren't that big.
That guy's not that big either.
Alright.
Who wants some?
Huh?
HUH?
YOU WANT SOME? HUH?
Whatever!
What?
[Mocking tone] Oh, what?
Oh, I'm sorry!
Did you want
some
there?
Ohh
whut?
Am I-
Am I too
AWESOME for you?
HUH?
[Normal tone] Oh what's that-
SOMEONE OVER THERE?
Huh.
Well, that sure was dangerous!
Glad it's all IN THE CLEAR!
Meant to hit that on the first try!
Boy! Sure hope no one's-
[Gunshots]
Sure hope no one's sneaking up...
UP BEHIND ME!
OR TO THE RIGHT OF ME!
OR TO THE RIGHT!
And by the way, these guys aren't taller than me,
or-or um, they ARE taller than me, but that's not 'cause I'm short!(No you're fun sized)
That's 'cause they...
are cheating!
Th-the mutation gene, it turns them into zombies, it's obviously...
making them seem higher than they are!
When in reality...
You know.
Bang!
Okay!
No big guy?
No big gai?
No big gai.
[CRASH]
Oh.
Woah!
WHOA HEY! THAT'S A BIG GUY!(YOU WANTED THIS!!!!)
OKAY, NEVERMIND THIS.
EUGHHHH!*Markimoo Freakout time:D*
OH BOY!
OHH BOY!
OHHHHHHH HEY!
[The manliest scream...ever]
AHH- okay, I guess...
Oh. So it was all just a dream.
[whooping sfx]
Well then.
[whooping intensifies]
... Okay.
I guess that was the sound of me being digested in my brain.
[soft rumble]
... Okay!
Ah- OH! There we go!
Okay, that's it! That's so cool!
Oh, that was so cool!
That was so cool, guys!
Aww, that was awesome!
Oh, that was AWESOME!
Oh, that was so cool!
Oh man, you have no idea. That was
frickin awesome!
I gotta make sure that... that didn't close out the recording on me.
Okay! So that was the Brookhaven Experiment!
Everything is FINE!
As obviously you guys saw, but everything is totally fine.
[The lovely Outro music fades in]
The recording's fine,
'cause obviously you just saw a video there.
Or else there wouldn't be one!
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
I'm refining the setup as I go?
But I need a lot of advice, because I can't really do a whole lot with my room,
but if I can make it a little better for you guys watching,
I will do my best.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Check out other cool games that I've played in virtual reality in the description below.
AND AS ALWAYS!
I will see YOU
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]
[Oh yes, shake that booty, Captain Ass Ass the Butt Pirate]